[Music]
let's play uh kill
mary okay but only with ryan gosling so
the ryan gosling from place beyond the
pines the ryan gosling from the notebook
and ryan gosling from lars and the real
girl okay well this is
fairly easy you go you marry
ryan from the notebook yeah totally i
would the the one from uh place beyond
the pine whew
right now
i know it's weird i know
what is your answer i guess
yeah totally
next let's do it with affleck
ugh again impossible argo ben affleck
okay goodwill hunting ben affleck okay
the town affleck i think i think i would
marry the band from uh
goodwill hunting yeah oh good choice
yeah well see you're like guys you want
a stupider boyfriend
i'm over here i don't know what i'm
doing i want to be his matt dammit i
want to be wicked smart
you gotta are you sitting on a lottery
ticket you're too much of a [ __ ] to
cash in god yeah
you stay with them the rest of your life
yeah so who are we killing i'm going to
kill the one from the town
i mean sorry sorry other way around i
want to kill one for margot yeah get rid
of it make enough of an impression that
70s beard and you know big 70s bush
getting out of here what if i came out
strong pro bush right now
any bush any interpretation of that face
i feel like girls look still look for
personality that that works out pretty
good oh and guys yeah they look for
personalities most guys although a lot
of them claim they want to have a really
intelligent girl and then
they meet one and they're threatened by
her intelligence or someone that wants
to wear pjs and watch game of thrones
and watch
want her to look like a victoria's
secret model like i think like kate
upton is really gorgeous yeah she's
really beautiful but okay what am i
gonna do take kate upton to dinner the
second i leave to wash my hands for two
seconds some sultan is gonna be like
hello my love assaulted yeah assault did
your did your sense of protectiveness
develop during aladdin
childhood screaming
blue jeans
i'm a terrified of a yago parrot why is
this an attractive assault
looking he's great he's a really good
looking why is he here why is he in new
york uh he was stalking kate upton
he was like my lord oh my god i found
her i brought you jewels like baby jesus
you